no until I know that you're serious I
will give I can I can surrender to you
so you're not even respecting a man's
pocket on the first day like I said 200
pounds is nothing to imagine that no you
don't respect the money because you just
said it's nothing because you're looking
at it unless he speaks he's not able to
afford to go on a date or whatever
you know no man is gonna stay anything
man could have his last 200 pounds bro
you don't date when you're broke
so you can't say that because men are
dating when they're broken
if he doesn't want to spend 200 pounds
on a date like what about me you need
200 pounds on a first date for what but
that's I didn't I didn't ask you said
for it no you said 200 pounds ain't
nothing to him yeah and then when and
then when all of these guys said no that
is something to me you shout on them you
said that you said they're not a high
enough caliber of man